un mot concernant les greffiers du
tribunal de grande instance de bobigny
ils sont en grève ce mercredi ils
protestent contre des conditions de
travail qu'il juge déplorable
les greffiers dénonce notamment des
manques d'effectifs et une surcharge de
travail
magistrats et avocats du tribunal les
ont rejoints pour apporter leur soutien
ils réclament plus de moyens et la
démission de la ministre de la justice
nicole belloubet ans les avocats sont là
aujourd'hui pour soutenir le mouvement
de grève des greffiers du tribunal
judiciaire de bobigny il faut savoir que
ces greffiers travaillent dans des
conditions inadmissibles avec un manque
de moyens évident manque de moyens
matériels manque de moyens humains
il faut savoir que très souvent ils
travaillent très tard le soir et
également du week-end
simplement pour éviter que le travail
n'avance pas il pourrait vider tous les
cabinets sombre sous la surcharge de
travail
c'est plus un ras-le-bol là c'est une
question d'urgence sur la santé on a des
burn out qui se multiplient ils veulent
au dessus personne ne veut en prendre
conscience
parce que ce qui les intéresse qui ce
qui leur apporte
c'est que les dossiers sorte que les
dossiers avancent on est là ce matin
pour se tenir le mouvement de grève des
greffiers mouvement de grève auquel se
sont joints les magistrats et
les avocats ne pouvait que se joindre à
ce mouvement puisque ça fait plus de
deux mois qu'on est en grève
ça fait deux semaines qu'on fait des
actions coup de poing pour essayé
d'alerter le gouvernement sur le fait
qu' on ne lâchera pas et là c'est le
premier jour mon voit vraiment l'unité
de la justice a fait plaisir à voir
mais on se bat tous pour la même chose